it's been more than 10 years since the
folks at Goldman Sachs dubbed Brazil
Russia India and China the BRIC
countries and lately other countries
have been trying to glom on to that
group Korea with the KH end maybe South
Africa with an S at the very end of the
word the thing is these countries are
actually very different they're big
economies they're growing their
important to the global economy but
they're very different and they're not
the only ones that should be getting
investors attention right now they're
certainly interesting things happening
in China but China is still using the
low-hanging fruit for its growth in the
global economy it's still using low
wages that come from people migrating in
from the countryside to the cities it's
still using its ability to export the
same products as a Korea or Japan but at
lower prices it's going to run out of
gas with those things eventually but
it's not going to happen for another few
decades Russia on the other hand still
depends to a large degree on commodities
for its growth it's a totally different
economy from China but that commodity
led growth can't last forever and the
question is will Russia be able to
convert all of the revenue that it gets
from selling its oil and natural gas and
other commodities into long-term growth
by investing in its people India is a
very different case because we've never
seen such an enormous country that also
happens to be a democracy trying to grow
using some of the same tools as a China
perhaps with big manufacturing bases but
also some other ones with a developing
service industry and finally Brazil
gives faith that you can grow in a way
where you allow all of the people in
your economy to benefit the Brazilian
government has been using good economic
policies combined with various types of
redistribution to try and ensure that
inequality doesn't become a byproduct of
their growth and in fact inequality has
been dropping in Brazil but these are
four very different stories and the
reason why investors should think about
other countries as places for assets in
their portfolio or maybe operations for
their business is because these four
countries are not the greatest places in
the world to do business they have a lot
of corruption they have on transparent
tax systems and regulations the customs
regimes are sometimes difficult to
navigate and they also don't have the
best protection for investors if you
look at other mid-sized countries like
for example a
a Malaysia or a turkey you find much
better places to do business so unless
you absolutely have to have an enormous
market with hundreds of millions of
people who can buy your products you can
go to other places where it's more
likely that the money you earn will make
it back to your home country because it
won't be eaten away by all these other
little problems